now LeBron James is on the way that's a
good basket and you know what I mean
LeBron James you make those shots all
night Sophia nugget says you know 13 is
full they started last
[Applause]
LeBron James and the Lakers have their
first league
same thing we saw Barton dude just go
rate it at Murray made six out of seven
shots and McKee he's gonna take the jump
shot he puts it up and in Joker's out on
McGee Nuggets switch for three LeBron
that but certainly the players and the
coaches have appreciated what he's
brought to the team this year and that
was for October and November ad with a
little shuffle it has worked out we wait
Harris in the lane nobody opened their
Lakers as we mentioned long toss Sally's
in inside Anthony Davis is away
[Music]
inside Davis store this is a good move
right there shot it right handed them
going left gonna go to work
caldwell-pope ed Davis was there this
tomorrow change the shot Davis is a web
where Rondo is still a gifted passer is
he not up over the top tried to use that
touch comes right back down to get the
first one here in the third quarter this
is one seven games tonight in the NBA
new it goes in first possession and
Anthony Davis Anthony Davis wide open
that's his bread butter in that little
top of the key 18-footer pick that up on
defense Davis for three comes up short
in transition so he likes to do he likes
to go right at you and then curl to that
left for the left hand fourth one Lakers
leak timeout Nuggets and that's the good
thing
that's the thing you got it you got to
keep banking to stay in the water kids
Davis of Davis lays down just more play
about Rondo after he passes off he just
keeps going through pushes Plumlee on
the one phanie Davis is a went to 25 to
24 21 that rebound
4 of 12 shooting David Henderson